BAIL HIM OUT IN A JOINT
STATEMENT LATER.
KARL ROVE, GOOD TO SEE YOU,
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
HERE WITH REACTION TO ALL OF THE
BREAKING NEWS -- YEAH,
ROBERT MUELLER AGREED TO END
TESTIFY.
THEY CHANGE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
LAW, KEN STARR IS WITH US.
YOU WORKED UNDER A VERY
DIFFERENT -- VERY DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE AN OPTION AS IT
RELATES TO TESTIFYING.
IN THE ISSUE, YOU ARE COMPELLED
TO RELEASE THIS.
INTERESTINGLY, IT WAS PEOPLE
LIKE JERRY NADLER WHO DIDN'T
WANT YOUR REPORT TO BE PUBLIC,
ALTHOUGH THE LAW COMPELLED IT,
AND YOU TOOK A LOT OF HEAT, IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY, FOR DOING YOUR
JOB.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT, SEAN.
FOR ME, IT WAS THE LONGEST DAY
BACK IN NOVEMBER OF 1998.
AND I THINK BOB MUELLER IS GOING
TO NOW HAVE A VERY SIMILAR
EXPERIENCE, AND IT WILL BE JUST
AS IT WERE FOR ME, FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF THE AISLE AT
THE TIME, THEY ARE GOING TO
BE -- AS YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING --
AND SENATOR GRAHAM WAS SAYING --
THEY'RE GOING TO BE VERY HARD
QUESTIONS FOR BOB MUELLER.
AND THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE.
I SHOULD HAVE GONE UP TO
TESTIFY.
AND BOB MUELLER SHOULD GO UP TO
I GREATLY RESPECT SENATOR GRAHAM
THAT IT IS OVER, BUT IN LIGHT OF
THE FACT THAT SOME 70 DEMOCRATS
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
ARE INCLINED FOR IMPEACHMENT,
THIS IS A LOGICAL STEP.
AND I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT DAY FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: WELL, I DO THINK
THERE ARE SOME VERY, VERY TOUGH,
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS FOR
BOB MUELLER.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND, FOR THE LIFE
OF ME, WITHOUT BROAD MANDATE, AS
I'VE BEEN SAYING.
DECADES-OLD -- BY THE WAY,
EVERYONE PAY YOUR TAXES, DON'T
LIE ON LOAN APPLICATIONS.
GOT IT.
DON'T LIE UNDER OATH.
BUT HOW DO YOU IGNORE A BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR, RUSSIAN DOSSIER
THAT WAS LEAKED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BY, WE BELIEVE, THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, TO
IMPACT THE ELECTION.
RUSSIAN LIES.
WHOSE OWN AUTHOR SAYS HE DOESN'T
KNOW IF ANY OF IT IS TRUE, WHICH
MAKES AN UNVERIFIABLE, BUT
BECOMES THE BASIS TO SPY ON NOT
ONLY CARTER PAGE, AND THERE WAS
OTHER SPYING ABROAD, BUT THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, TRANSITION, AND
PRESIDENCY.
NOW THAT WAS ALL BASED ON
SOMETHING THAT IS UNVERIFIABLE,
BASED ON THE OWN AUTHOR.
HOW DO THEY IGNORE THAT, SIR?
>> IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
AND I THINK WHAT BOB MUELLER
WILL SAY IS LOOK, THIS WAS
HANDED TO ME, I DIDN'T HAVE
OCCASION TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT
HOW IT CAME TO ME.
JUST HEY, HERE IS THE JOB, NOW
GO DO THE JOB.
SUPPOSED TO
AS OPPOSED TO LOOKING
TO THE BACKGROUND OF THE JOB.
THESE ARE FAIR QUESTIONS YOU ARE
RAISING, SEAN PEERED SO MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT ABOUT THE WHY,
THE WHEREFORE, YOU HAVE RAISED
SOME OF THEM HERE
TONIGHT.
I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT DAY.
I KEEP GOING BACK TO THE CONCEPT
OF ACCOUNTABILITY, BECAUSE WHEN
BOB MUELLER HELD HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE BUT DIDN'T TAKE
QUESTIONS, I THINK WE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
WHY WON'T YOU RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS?
AND NOW I THINK IT IS MOST
APPROPRIATE THAT HE GOES OVER TO
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE, BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE -- DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS -- WANTED THIS.
AND I'M GLAD IT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK HE HAS A
HARD TIME ANSWERING THE PEOPLE
HE APPOINTED?
WEISSMANN?
HOW DO YOU APPOINT
HILLARY CLINTON'S ATTORNEY?
HOW DO YOU ONLY APPOINT
DEMOCRATS, NO REPUBLICANS?
HOW DOES HE ANSWER THAT?
>> YEAH, AND I'VE RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT, REALLY,
FROM THE GET-GO.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY, SEAN, WHEN
QUESTIONS WERE RAISED BACK
DURING MY INVESTIGATION THAT OH,
YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN, I REACHED
OUT SPECIFICALLY TO THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE BECAUSE THE
APPEARANCE OF FAIRNESS AND
EVENHANDEDNESS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, IT'S VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
SO WE BROUGHT IN SAM OF WATER
GAINED FAME ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE, BROUGHT IN A DEPUTY,
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT, VOTED
FOR -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO GIVE
THE PUBLIC ASSURANCES THAT WHAT
YOU ARE DOING IS FAIR.
AND IT'S EVENHANDED.
THAT IS, I THINK, A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION FOR
BOB MUELLER TO ANSWER.
>> Sean: I WAS NOT IMPRESSED
WITH THE NINE AND A HALF MINUTE
DISASTROUS PRESS CONFERENCE.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE WITH THE
DEMOCRATS THINK, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT PEERED ALTHOUGH
BOB MUELLER'S PEOPLE APPARENTLY